people go to movies to be distracted and
entertained that's basically the reason
movies exist sometimes those movies are
so good doing their job that they
managed to distract audiences even with
glaring plot holes or lapses in logic
not many people kicked up a fuss over
some of the dumbest moments in these
2017 movies so we're here to shed light
on them get ready to tear a few holes in
some of 2017 s best flicks spoilers
ahead a simple message
spider-man homecomings fairy scene was a
lot of fun but it never would have
happened if not for a flawed whole
bigger than the whole vulture put in
that fairy the only reason that whole
sequence happened is because Tony Stark
didn't think it was important enough to
send a quick reply to his proteges to
elaborate let's go back to the awkward
argument between Iron Man and Spidey
those weapons were out there and I try
to tell you about it but you didn't
listen none of this would have happened
if you would just listen to me I did
listen kid who do you think called the
FBI huh it's great that Stark was paying
attention but that would have been a
nice thing to mention before Peter tried
to stop everyone himself
honestly young Peter Parker wasn't
acting insubordinate when he boarded
that ferry he was simply doing his
heroic duty because he thought no one
else was going to all of the movies
troubles following the ferry scene like
him fighting vulture solo in a
sweatshirt instead of his high-tech suit
are a direct result of Tony's inability
to respond to messages in the timely
manner a simple text to say the FBI was
handling it would have saved everyone a
lot of headaches
unfortunately the world's most
notoriously irresponsible billionaire
playboy just couldn't be bothered to do
something that's simple assassin
incentives toward the final third of
John wick Chapter two John breaks some
rules and scores a 7 million dollar
bounty on his head
thanks to this bounty all of the
assassins in New York City pop out of
the woodwork and try to take a stab at
wick what doesn't make sense here is
that in the previous movie there was a
two million dollar bounty on Rick's head
and not one random assassin perked up at
the offer when the offer got doubled to
4 million only one ultra desperate
assassin tried to take on Rick and that
didn't end well this lack of challenge
stems from the fact that wick has a
reputation for being the underworld
boogeyman John wasn't exactly the boot
he was the one you said to kill the
booby man yet in John wick to everyone
and their grandmother gave it a shot for
7 million boogeyman or not 7 million
dollars is a lot of money mr. wick but
is it enough to warrant going after the
man who single-handedly dismantled the
Russian mob it just doesn't add up
not so secret island as great as Wonder
Woman was it was chock full of dumb
moments how is Steve Trevor able to
infiltrate the German army without a
shred of identification or the ability
to speak German with a proper accent how
is Wonder Woman able to cross no man's
land without any of these bullets
hitting her moments like these were
overlooked in favor of the movies many
strong points but it doesn't change the
fact that the plot was sloppy the
clearest example of this is when the
mascara is discovered by Steve Trevor
the first man to stumble upon it even
though it's clearly within arm's reach
of England and uses an invisibility
shield that's penetrable by literally
anyone think about it Diana and Steve
used a sailboat to reach London from
famous Keira in one night so the
amazon's secret island has to be pretty
close even with the tug to tow them part
way boring
we got lucky we caught a ride we made
some good time and considering Steve
could randomly fly through the islands
cloaking shield as well as the Nazi
boats following him it's ludicrous to
suggest that no one had stumbled upon
famous Kira before that 8 ex machina for
such a great movie war for the Planet of
the Apes sure stumbles when detailing
how the Apes managed to outmaneuver
their captors at the film's climax from
within the confines of a
maximum-security penitentiary that has
guards patrolling 24/7 dozens of apes
are able to sneak away via a convenient
hole in the dirt floor of their cell not
one guard notices all the Apes vanishing
from the cell and as if that weren't
preposterous enough the movie then sends
all the young chimps across electrical
wires right up up the guards heads not
one guard happens to look up none of
those roving spotlights casts a monkey
shaped shadow on the ground even though
all of this happens at night an entire
internment camps where the chimps aren't
just going to slink away within a few
hours completely unnoticed forgotten
blob toward the end of guardians of
galaxy vol 2 ego unleashes an alien
tumor that starts gobbling up earth this
blob grows to massive proportions
wreaking havoc on an entire town before
it's stopped given that the prologue
took place in 1980 and the rest of the
movie was set 34 years later it's pretty
safe to assume that all that blobbing
happened around 2014 and the emcee use
chronology so you think there would be
some mention of it across the bevy of
other MCU movies that take place after
that but everyone just seems to have
forgotten about that little town in
Missouri and all the places that got
wrecked by egos blue goo suspicious
resurrection at the very end of Justice
League we see that Superman has revived
as Clark Kent alter-ego but isn't that
kind of suspicious a little maybe a lot
of people saw him get buried while
returning from the grave might not be a
big deal for kal-el humans don't really
tend to do that at least not without
something getting thrown at them
now we'll have to get more stuff even
worse can't worked for the Daily Planet
none of those investigative journalists
co-workers thought it was fishy that his
demise and returned perfectly coincided
with Superman's these policemen couldn't
put it together after Louis said his
name in front of everyone
Clark the only explanation is that Clark
Kent was revived solely so that he could
tear his shirt open at the end of the
film that's a good reason right
missing SIF for all the fun thor
ragnarok provides some things just don't
make sense
specifically the absence of the warrior
lady SIF basically SIF doesn't seem to
exist anymore
after having a serious role in the first
Thor movie and an appearance in Thor the
dark world lady SIF is nowhere to be
found during the destruction of Oz guard
even the Warriors three got an ending to
their arcs as anticlimactic as it was
the fact that SIF got snubbed just seems
like a massive oversight Marvel had
Kevin Feige did give a vague explanation
for her absence saying what is Loki been
doing on that throne and guise of Odin
he would have to get rid of Heimdall
because Heimdall can see everything
which is probably an answer to a
question I've been asked a few times
today SIF was probably banished she's
off somewhere well that could work but
Heimdall was banished and still got a
story arc SIF didn't even get attacked
on death scene or align a dialogue that
addresses her absence she's just not
there silly humans Kong Skull Island is
a big silly movie about a big gorilla
it's a lot of fun but let's face it you
don't go into this kind of thing
expecting a water-type plot still one
plot decision made absolutely no sense
here's the scoop a team of researchers
and soldiers are tasked with
infiltrating Skull Island which is
surrounded by a permanent storm like the
Bermuda Triangle or like that aluminum
foil hat that I like to wear in the
weekends to pass through this natural
hazard they bring a massive ship and
then abandon it in favor of a few
open-door helicopters sure they need the
ship intact to get them away from the
island again but they could have gotten
a lot closer on the boat rather than
brave hurricane winds and if
helicopters how far away is this island
50 miles maybe more take us closer you
want to launch you do it from here
gee thanks random boat guy minimum
maximum security at the outset of ghost
in the shell' super soldier cyborg major
is created to do the bidding of a
sinister corporation when she stops
following orders the company's goons
trap major in a maximum security
fortress well as it turns out the
facility isn't very secure at all all it
takes for major to bust out of there is
a light scuffle with a few guards and
then some off-screen action had the
movie played by its own rules she would
have been stopped before she escaped
from her deactivation van this whole set
piece and the sequence within it is just
poorly thought-out maybe next time you
can't assign me better thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]